God you know I got these ear pieces in
sometimes you're a guest comes back for
cursor work I have no idea what you just
told me David Spade is everything okay
we're good I was just saying her
countdown was like an a so on it's
amazing 8:37 you are the second guest
that we've had in a row Jeff Garlin was
fixated with Britney's changes yeah the
only sports guys so we're in
professional like movie sets
yes so we don't ever we see that quiet
than the point yes she's like 29 28 and
then I get nervous because I go is that
where we going all the way to one yeah
because I sort of roughly in my head so
what what type of count what you like it
like a 10 down from 10 or 5 right Oh
Betsy yeah there ya stupid to it hey
guys how are you uncomfortable look at
this chair you know last time you were
here you sat cross-legged on that chair
yeah I'm gonna stay on the edge this
time because I feel like these are
sports themed this is a catcher's mitt
or something do we go over there no it's
like something with we've had some
guests on these are watery bar that I
think something like that and that
people who have these chairs in their
house so like oh I have these chairs but
I don't think it's looking for comfort
just at the home but uh have you ever
sat on a catcher's mitt before it's sort
of what must feel like one time when I
went to Johnny bench's house we saw him
just last week in Washington DC for real
for real I grew up with the Reds I like
the red did you have the Johnny Bench
batter up in your backyard which is the
you know that that pole that you'd spin
around ball and hit it yeah you had it
of course I had that in the Evel Knievel
doll that run exactly I had all this
cool stuff too I'm dating myself I'm
older than you but I had some you know
that much older than me
yeah we're not gonna say numbers here
cuz we got some female fans out there
but we're gonna keep it in general
what's distinguished its distinguished
David I don't want that bad you look
great man I got my hair cut you look
great
this is as good as it gets Potter but
you just had a birthday did you not yeah
what'd you do to celebrate your birthday
try to make sure no one knew is my
birthday are you serious you have that
you're that you don't like celebrate I
used to I used to have like a big ray
and it got too expensive and then all
those stars that came were bigger stars
and they put all the girls and I was
like I don't I'm at the party where I'm
the weakest star here any one party yeah
one dime I can't I was eating before the
party started and Stallone Bruce Willis
and Kevin Costner chemo is this thing
gone yet I go oh oh here we go
okay we're doing it and then we all did
karaoke with a live band and stuff and
Kid Rock would sing Amy what's your
go-to karaoke song
Kid Rock told me I cannot sing he said
uh you're bad I mean he jokes around
with me but the truth is even my mom
said you can't sing but I can you know
everyone karaoke yeah I sometimes do
Bowie or Tom Petty cuz I sort of can
fake it like it's more like an
impression right it's not fun for
everybody else but I can do a few lines
but it's hard to do the whole song so I
just watch everyone else do you just
watch everyone else do karaoke so you
didn't have a birthday party this year
we went to Javier's who went down a
Newport and just had some buddies and we
played golf and no no okay yeah it was
easy enough at this point we can't get
two bananas about it do you want to tell
David how you spent your birthday party
Chris every year we do a burger fantasy
draft because he's a big fantasy
football player David Spade yeah we go
to this place in Venice that has like
gourmet burgers and we draw names out of
a hat and we do a fantasy draft where
everyone orders one and then we draft
halves of each burger so you may not get
the burger that you order but it's just
kind of a throwing a little fantasy
aspect it's live Ian bell peppers on my
desk right there levy on bell peppers
well I like that that sounds what do you
think there's no there's no girls there
obviously no girls yes would you would
those only hamburger halves correct
it's a minutes at guys only his lovely
and beautiful better half who you know
very well yes the very funny Sarah Tiana
is great as a matter of fact you sat
down you looked at him you go Sarah
Tiana pointed right out it's right not
invited not invited like she wouldn't be
able to guys
guys night guys night I got a play both
sides guys now yeah okay I did a fantasy
draft you know I was 11 and 3 last year
and I still bombed out and I got fourth
ooh I really fell apart you know what
and you're winning all year and you go
bottom is about to come out cuz it's
always you know sort of a crapshoot
right I was crushing it and then Shawn
Jack's deshaun Watson yes he wiped out
and went down and that was the beginning
of the second half and then I really
fell apart did you draft him what did
you pick him up to join the mob isn't
that why the waiver wire I got so good
it was so did you feel really good about
yourself I feel smart yeah like a GM and
nut it's really all about the waiver
where cuz the draft usually the first
one or two of mine
bust out somehow because I'm picking
names from a couple years back ya know
and then I could get des and he craps
out on here something right so I was
pretty good I always go quarterback
early and everyone tells me not to but
it actually is not a bad idea
dude that's you're supposed to not do
that I know but I can't help but I see
him sitting there and I pluck them so
take it I get stressed would you take
this time around I can't say but um what
is your draft we don't even know no
we're Jodie my buddy back there does it
with me he's the Commish of the one of
just idiots and then I have a happy
Madison one who's in that one anybody
that works of art is Fortson in that one
you know sports is sort of a puss he
doesn't do it any but he talks a big
game and he won't do fantasy why I don't
know you know those guys ago I'm like a
real gambler and you know okay young
fantasies fun I like it I agree it's so
good day my buddy had David Johnson of
course he's like I got David Jon snap
what was that that was such a buzzkill
but doesn't he want more money now and
he didn't even play oh that's correct
the tough position said he wants to do
all right we're back in 60 seconds with
David spins made the new book from
audible a Polaroid guy into snapchat
world Netflix his father of the year and
you said you'd be kind enough to play
phone a friend of when we when we play
what France Rotter and pharmaceutical
yeah they're already over there alright
we're back in 60 seconds with David
Spade on a burger guys getting excited
by David Spade is here at David Spade on
Twitter and you could catch father a
year father of the year on Netflix
you still know you're sitting
cross-legged it's it's more comfortable
it's more comfortable through here
so you just said you you learned a New
Hampshire accent for father of the year
what does not listen they wanted me to
like acts like I was in New Hampshire
like guys I've sort of skated through it
for about 22 years I really need to
bring the DeNiro on now so I had to go
to a dialect coach because the movie I'm
a New Hampshire dad I'm sort of horrible
at it and I'm a drunk and and I get in
fights the whole movie mm-hmm so I went
to a dialect coach but it's not even
Boston which I thought oh you can kind
of fake it people like this year a
Maquis mock you know but they go no it's
New Hampshire so oh the struggle and
then everyday on the set
directors of New Hampshire so you go
it's sort of like this that instead of
you know it's tricky but anyway did you
ever say so see in March for the Oscars
but that's the summary smash cut to
smash cut to down tell us yeah downtown
Los Angeles that's when I fell out of
the truck at the beginning oh my god
yeah I heard that yeah that's a little
piece of it but that's different than
Boston I can't I don't even remember
retain one thing after the movie wrapped
well you're calm that area I'm from
Maine there's Maine - a little bit
different Maine is a lot thicker see to
be honest there's what cuz you're close
to Canada I don't understand no it's
just it's that the lack of ours and
something to do with the lobsters could
be done lobster could be there yeah and
the new book from audible a Polaroid guy
in a snapchat world I think I know what
you mean by that but you're just an old
why why is that well like I was more in
the Polaroid world
growing up and now it's all this out
stuff so I sort of compare the two like
my generator I'm not like a fault I
guess I am a full generation away but
and then how it is with dating how it is
with I used to keep my dog in the
backyard there's a dog and everyone
keeps it inside you know I sort of go
over what was like for me now where I
feel like I realize I'm out of it when I
deal with everything going on in the
world now so you're not on snapchat you
were not on sir I'm not I'm on I'm
you're on twitter IG Instagram yeah
right I didn't do my I didn't jump in I
go these things are passing fancies I'm
so stupid right I'm like Facebook will
never catch on then by Twitter I go hard
I gotta get on one of these so I did
Twitter and Instagram basically you have
a Sam who's not on it at all right oh
yeah he uh he's not only does he doesn't
really monitor any ESP but when we do
that comedy tour he was putting stuff on
Instagram you almost have to you do I
know you do people don't even know where
to get they don't know how to they just
go right there if you're not there they
give up on you right so I just put
stupid stuff I'm doing on there okay
yeah you know I've got a couple of facts
that we've noticed from your your IMDB
page we want to see if it's true or
false okay you got that
all right who's David Spade here it'll
just a quick celebrity Truffaut worked
as a skateboard shop employee true or
false the bear cover in Tempe right by
ASU yes what was that like in his
skateboard shop just it was good I used
to skate
did the old AZ pipes you did yeah okay I
did the pools how good were you I got to
where I could do aerial once you could
get aerials out of pools that lost me
okay because I I tried to an area on an
aerial axle stall and then I fell
backwards into the pool and I broke both
my wrists yes then I got better
I broke my wrist again and then my mom
said you can't scape where'd I go cuz
you're so worried about me she was no
because you're horrible I think with
that but I still like follow Tony Hawk
on Instagram to be like hey I'm in the
mix yeah yeah the one time Tony Hawk was
here he put me on a skateboard and I
fell right on my alright oh yeah alright
it's still good I can't believe how good
he is I'm not I'm not very good at it at
all right there learn how to fall you
can run in a straight line I heard you
can I can too
I could definitely do that next fact you
have a degree in business from Arizona
State University is you I really only I
didn't even graduate I went to SCC and
then I went to issue four semester but I
was in a fraternity so I was bombing out
so bad I started in stand up and I just
bailed so then your stand-up career took
you out of college basically thank God
it was a loll there obviously but all
right excited to know I'm probably bout
180 credits of so then your first season
on Saturday Night Live you only appeared
three times on the airs that's right
what what happened you're just not good
no so I wrote but I'm writing against a
nut cart you know the competition there
with just the writers are Conan O'Brien
Bob Odenkirk Robert Smigel mmm Jack
Handey and then you've got Jim down
everyone is already good then you're
also Mike Meyers is writing and all the
cast and Sandlin Dennis Miller so
everyone's so way better I didn't I
wasn't ready for it and then I was just
sort of not quite at that level then I
got better over the years but just too
tough so hold on but Jack Handey was the
name of an actual writer
yeah the deep thought he thought well
they actually his deep thought was even
once of sketches that were great did he
voice with all those weird the cat who
drives a car yeah every young bird is I
know that's not true
plug in my aux car no don't come on
that's young people no no we go it's not
nice I'm a Polaroid guy in a in a
snapchat world yeah so SNL was tough but
I got on more and more I never got on
his and Dana Carvey was a better version
of me he was so good that I was sitting
right there mostly they thought he was
retiring and he didn't so I was the
backup I was you know Aaron Rodgers so
what was the what was the one big moment
for you to break I think I did one
called the receptionist that was pretty
good
and then I start doing Hollywood minute
and then Lauren my boss was like yeah
yeah do that again next week come on huh
oh he's talking to me okay and then two
weeks later do it again am i okay I got
some and then the last one that we've
got here you have a tattoo of Calvin
from Calvin and Hobbes on your left
bicep given to you by Sean Penn is that
a true story that was from signing live
it he was in town I didn't really know
him but I heard he could he was trying
to do
tattoos on potatoes and stuff just to
see if he could do it so I said oh be
funny my arms like a potato so I called
I got his number from someone and he
said yeah I'll do it so he came over and
then he I took him to some biker bar
with some Hells Angels and he couldn't
do the one I wanted so we had to pick
one right then because we were filming
it and I interviewed him while he did
this horrible tattoo
you still haven't yeah it's horrible to
the point when I started I took it off
once like it takes a while but then I go
now I like it just because it's why'd
you choose Calvin just cuz we were all
like what's the easiest one he can do
out of the newspaper so I was like can
you do Snoopy I knew it was gonna be
horrible thrust my life but I needed a
bit for the show it's before jackass
guys there you go Wow we're gonna play
the game yeah we you let's do it
cyclists are pharmaceutical with what
David Spade is the as the phone-a-friend
here are you ready for you guys it's
there I'm asking them and they get to
ask you for help these are the names of
an actual cyclist in the Tour de France
that wrapped up today or a
pharmaceutical you ready guys
please that please use David Spade
liberal no idea okay here we go
burn all I know this one David Spade
what do you got I thought you wouldn't
finish no no burn all that's the name
it's easy to a cyclist or pharmaceutical
I think that's burn all burn on neither
the last name first name of a cyclist
what do you think cyclist it is the name
of a Colombian cyclist two foes up one
nothing I thought it was that okay next
one Avista Avista cyclist or pharmacist
totally totally it's not a cyclist it's
at a pharmaceutical good do you know cuz
you're taking it I'm taking it as a
pharmaceutical I'm gonna say cyclist
what do you think I know this guy hasta
LaVista nope that's not him it's an
actual and there you're definitely not
taking it Mike Delta because it treats
and prevents osteoporosis in women who
are postmenopausal come on
pharmaceutical is up to nothing you need
to come
today I should know that here's another
one your boy your boy cyclist or
pharmaceutical your voice cyclist Mike
definitely a cyclist what do you think
David Spade tapping out you're both
wrong it's a pharmaceutical you have to
take your voice to make sure that you
have an antibody to regulate your body's
immune system nobody's got one point
check your doctor before you head sure
your amador amadora pharmaceutical Chris
cyclist I say soccer player Costa Rican
so you might have been in yes he's a
cyclist all right this was last one this
is the last one you need to tie up or or
win okay here we go
valgrind Beltran David Spade is here for
your help if you needed value a pharmacy
I'll go at David Mike del 2 fo for the
win pharmaceutical he's not he's a
Denmark Ryder you guys are the worst
pharmacy cyclists players you can't tell
the difference can you I didn't even if
we didn't get one I'm also watching
David get tattooed by Sean Penn over
here you look at it I'm watching video
yes we're trying to get a turnaround for
the Plus block there's an actual video
yeah yeah it's a four minute and his
skit
she's I was asking these questions he
couldn't concentrate any catwalk what
you look terrified hurts - I didn't know
that part yeah but I couldn't drink
because it makes your blood then he came
two hours late cuz that car I sent him
got lost so he came a new book from
audible a Polaroid guy and a snapchat
world and check out Netflix his father
of the year right now on Netflix good to
see you dude yeah thanks guys fun please
like anytime I love it any fun here it's
a great show you got it thank you David
Spade here check him out on twitter and
IG but not on snapchat right here on the
rich s yeah the Rich Eisen show we
days at noon eastern on audience